there's a clip from robert rodriguez
2001 movie spy kids that more than
anything encapsulates how i feel about
city skylines today this hardware is
getting in the way of my creative
abilities
so obviously that was just a joke at the
start of this video but honestly it's
also relevant to this episode although
before i jump into that i just want to
quickly give some critiques of spy kids
just to make sure that this is uh not
quite muddy waters in terms of copyright
infringement i think it's the best movie
from the spy kids series and also floop
has one of the best redemption arcs in
cinema history um if you disagree with
me you're you're wrong frankly anyway
it's also somewhat relevant to city
skylines because
well tackling the the hardware but
definitely also software limitations of
the game is something that was really
important to me when trying to recreate
brussels and frankly also just makes
recreating brussels impossible
and
you can see one of the uh
one of the effects of this on screen
right now as i'm removing a bunch of
roads to dial it back a bit to the start
in the last episode i got many questions
about how i actually got the map how i
put the terrain into the game and got
the road map on it um which was just the
base that i started from so when it
comes to to the to the terrain i use
terrain.party which is a website that
you can use to get a city skyline sized
boundary box on google maps and download
height maps
from real world data and put that into
the game and import these in the terrain
editor very handy and very easy to do if
you want to get a real-life geography
into the game so that's what i did for
the terrain and then for the roads i use
the open street map import mod which
i will link both of these tools down in
the description so you can try them
yourself the open street map mod also
includes a whole process of how to
recreate things and create overlays
in its description as well so if you
want to get an idea of generally how i
went about this recreation you can find
it there
but
i honestly don't know if i want to
recommend it because one of the problems
is what you're seeing right now i had to
remove many roads in my map because um i
had a very basic roadmap generated from
openstreetmap data of just the highways
and main arterial roads that go through
the city
but often what openstreetmap import mod
does is it creates way more nodes than
would be necessary to create these
in-game
roads and usually when it comes to
straight sections it's not too bad but
especially if you get into curved roads
what it tends to do is create many small
segments of straight roads that all
together create a curve
instead of you know just creating a few
segments of curved roads and not only
does it kind of mess up the shape a
little bit if you're looking for a
perfectly shaped road you might want to
draw them by hand anyway but it also
creates a huge amount of nodes and let
it be know that knowing that highways
also feature lots of curves and the same
goes for the brussels road layout in
general so
i hit the node limit at the start of
this episode the note limit in city
skylines is somewhere around 33 000
actually don't have it by hand right now
it's a number that
well all things considered you probably
don't want to reach if you're building
all of your roads by hand but because
the main roads were imported using this
mod
i ended up hitting this note limit
pretty early and because i had already
placed many roads in the city by hand
it was a shorter process to remove all
of the automatically imported roads and
redo them by hand than it would be to
create an entire map from scratch and do
it all by hand to make sure i didn't hit
the note limit too early um but what
this effectively meant for me was that
the next few hours and by a few hours i
should probably
actually say quite quite many hours
we're all spent getting rid of specific
sections of roads and trying to open up
space a little bit in that node count so
that i could build more roads all in an
attempt to see just how much of brussels
i could
kind of realistically recreate before i
ended up hitting the note limits because
there's only a certain amount of road
segments and intersections that you can
build in city skylines until things
start breaking down and you can go
over this maximum number but the further
you go and this is why the number
honestly is hard to
to pin into a specific number even
though you can find a specific number
mentioned is because it starts slowly
breaking down at least that's my
experience at some point your save will
just not open anymore and at some point
before that the roads will just not have
zones next to them anymore so you can
lay down roads but you can't actually
zone or place buildings next to it
so this is all a very careful balancing
act of
trying to make my roads
node efficient as much as possible and
to see how much of brussels i can
actually lay down until the maximum
capacity of the game is truly reached
and i really have to give up at that
point
and that's really part of the test of
building brussels it's not even so much
to try and recreate all of brussels
realistically but see and test the
limits of city skylines itself
so the next topic that needs to be
discussed is the overlay i also got a
few questions about how i made the
overlay specifically and
i'm a little bit ashamed to admit i
don't have a specific method for it
all i did here is take a screenshot of
google maps and then mess around with
the screenshot
quite a bit in paint.net inverting the
colors adding an alpha layer and making
sure that only the roads remain visible
and trying to get it to be as much as
good as a of a resolution as possible
and
it was a
kind of a try-on-error process and it
doesn't really lead to the best results
as you might be able to tell some roads
are quite clear to see but all together
the overlay isn't very high resolution
and you inevitably also end up with
these labels that just show up on the
map like volume which you can see on the
bottom right there
and
well especially given that this is
brussels and many of the labels will be
there in french and dutch these cover
huge parts of neighborhoods and make it
essentially impossible to see where the
roads are going there so the process is
far from streamlined and the results is
far from streamlined as well which is
why i wouldn't recommend going about it
this way and why i also don't have
a good method to turn into a tutorial
for people to copy i honestly wouldn't
recommend you try and do it this way
i did seek out ways to create vector
images of cities
but very often the problem would be
geographic
projection of whichever map you're using
because the base map uses the same
projection as google maps i couldn't get
maps from some other websites that
create vectors and make a slightly
better overlay because then
it would be slightly warped in
comparison to the terrain and getting
the terrain and the roads locations to
match up exactly is of course a lot more
important so whatever it is that you're
doing in terms of methods of putting the
terrain and the roads into the game you
want to make sure that you're using the
same projection for both of these
methods and
that makes things a little bit more
difficult
also
for those that have seen project oslo
which i did a few years ago which all
together i think was a lot more
successful and actually turned into a
usable city unlike
brussels here inevitably will be
i used more or less the same method in
there
and nowadays with the knowledge that i
now have
i would say the best way to actually
create an overlay in the game is to use
qgis
which is a program that allows you to do
basically stuff with map things anybody
who's studied geography or urban studies
or anything in that corner of things has
probably
worked with it before and it's a great
way to try and get a real vector based
overlay that you can
get a very reliable transparent
background to and also render in a
higher resolution
overall it's a much better solution and
i would like to make a tutorial about
this in the near future when this is
coming out exactly i don't know but i
definitely want to make a tutorial about
how to recreate cities in this game
the main thing i just want to say here
today is
what you're watching right now is not
the best way so i'm not going to go that
much further into it
one thing i will say is that using qgis
also has the added advantage of being
able to have much more control over your
vector image and choosing certain colors
for certain row types so for instance
you might want the lines for highways to
turn up yellow and the lines for
arterial roads to be red and the lines
for local residential streets to be
green and this will just help a lot in
city skylines as well and make it a lot
easier to copy these roads by hand
because if you're building by hand like
i am right here you also have to keep of
course google maps open in another tab
and
well constantly look at it and try to
reference what kind of roads you find in
different places and by making better
overlays you can streamline that process
a lot as well so all together it's not
really the best method that i was using
to make brussels here a year ago but
that was with the knowledge i had at the
time and honestly
at this point i have a lot more
experience recreating cities in this
game so there's that
now i want to take some time not to be a
negative nancy this whole video and
actually talk about some of the comments
that i got on the last video because
they were really cool to read i read all
of the comments which you might notice
if i if you see that i'm also liking all
of the comments um but anyway there were
some some really cool responses there
also about people who are studying
geography or or some some kind of
urbanism studies in uni and have used
city skylines in school projects which i
suspect has happened a lot and it's
always been interesting for me uh just
to think about as a thought experiment
how much city skylines has done for
people actually studying this field i
know for me and i'm completely unashamed
to say this it definitely pushed me a
lot into studying urbanism i was always
interested in cities and playing games
like like simcity when i was younger
but never as much and as hardcore as
i've played city skylines
at least for a few years um
and it was one of the reasons i started
studying urbanism which is
um
i guess it sounds kind of stupid but
then again i think it it often happens
that people end up studying whatever it
is that they're studying because of some
kind of pop culture product or something
that they grew up with and that's fine
we need more light-hearted things in
this world that that bring and bring an
audience to very serious topics and i
think that's what city skylines excels
at of course it's not perfect there are
many problems with this game in terms of
urbanism discourse
most of all i think
the fact that it's made highways super
popular and people love building
junctions that in real life have
displaced people and turned cities into
centric unsustainable polluting messes
uh but it's fun in the game i i kind of
get it um but on the other hand i think
it's done some great things as well i
think it spread the the knowledge that
roundabouts are the superior type of
intersection to millions of people and
examples like that which i always like
to quote so yeah all together it's a
great game and it can push people into
this field which is just awesome
and i saw a lot of stories in the
comments reflecting on this as well i
also had some really interesting
conversations with people who work in
cities or politicians in cities uh so
thanks for that as well you know who you
are um and it seems altogether there are
so many people interested in how and and
if city skylines could be used in
serious purposes the main struggle is
just
getting people in the right place to
where it can actually happen and you can
experiment with it
which i would agree is also the the
biggest issue i think there's a lot
possible with this game and it can be a
real playground for for urbanism ideas
but it's difficult to link the audience
that could use it but doesn't know the
game versus the people that play the
game but don't know how to
actually get into real urbanism and link
these people together in some way and
that's something that i will still grind
my gears on for the near future
and it's it's honestly one of the main
conclusions i had from building brussels
and looking into the case studies that
city skylines have been used in it's all
been very exploratory and it seems like
every single time anybody has done
anything with this game they had to
reinvent the wheel and kind of start
over and explain everything to everybody
um so it's difficult to make progress in
that sense as well
but there is a real potential and as far
as i've looked into it
i think uh
digital twin cities are definitely the
future
there are so many technologies that are
popping up with it nowadays and some of
the biggest cities in europe i know have
digital models that are used within
their municipal organizations to model
all kinds of statistics within the city
and
big data is a huge topic that likes to
be combined with this as well
so i think city skylines can somewhat be
placed in the same corner of thought
just with a less detailed less
professional but on the other hand also
more approachable angle perhaps
so that's where i'm kind of coming from
with that all that to say
the only reason that i really started
uploading this brussels series because
um like you probably know by now i've
voiced my discontent with the actual
model so many times is just to start
this conversation and actually open up
to the rest of the world i guess that
i've been having uh this conversation
and that i'm thinking about this topic
and
somewhere behind the scenes i'm still
trying to think about it and see what
can be done with it and possibly you'll
find some more things on my youtube
channel about it as well
i
i've always been thinking about if there
was a good way to
put this out into the world and and make
a video about it or something maybe even
a video essay but all things considered
i just don't feel like i know enough
about the topic to to talk about it with
any kind of authority uh so instead i
just like to open the conversation and
see what other people are thinking and
you guys uh share lots of interesting
stuff so that was really cool thank you
and let's move on to the next chapter
so after a year of thinking about this
game i came up with a hot take that i
also think is an inevitable conclusion
to make about this game and that is that
modding is simultaneously the best and
the worst thing to happen to this game
it's the best because it allows for so
many new possibilities and it is
basically changed the gaming experience
for most of its players uh to be almost
unrecognizable from what the game was
like when it came out in 2015
um i think the only thing that's really
just the same still is the ui and even
that has gotten so many new buttons
added to it depending on which and
however many mods you've added to the
game
and there are so many things from the
assets that people use to plop down new
buildings that the game doesn't come
with to the trees especially the trees
everybody likes to keep them custom
because custom trees are just
a lot more realistic than the in-game
ones although in this case i did stick
with the in-game trees because i figured
it would be better to stick with low
poly models although in hindsight i'm
also not sure how smart that was because
there are plenty of low poly models on
the steam workshop as well but it's
something i went with here and then of
course there are the game changing mods
that either overhaul the traffic ai or
allow you to create completely new
intersections mess with the nodes uh
change the entire gameplay mechanics the
way that people live their lives in the
game or just remove some mechanics from
the game altogether it's all really
game-changing and although the hardcore
modding community is really niche and i
think people in that community often
overestimate just how part of the big
how big of a part of the community of
the game they are most players play the
game very lightly modded
playing completely unmodded and without
dlcs is very rare at this point
so
all things considered
it's it's safe to say that it's changed
the game a lot especially considering
most popular content of this game
is definitely quite heavily modded
if not using that many assets and things
like that then definitely using some
base mods like move it or traffic
manager or basic graphic changes so
all of this stuff is really awesome but
at the same time the more mods and
assets you add to the game the more
complex it becomes as well not just for
the the computer to handle but also for
players to handle and i think this is
one of the biggest paradoxes in a sense
that
it's the mods that make this game as
good as it is
but there's a certain point where the
mods just make it more and more complex
and it raises the barriers of entry and
my whole idea was
seeing if city skylines could be used in
real life urbanism at all but in order
for it to be used and used to any amount
of detail or customizability you want to
add mods to it and change it so that it
can be more realistic and you can
customize things but the more mods you
add the harder it becomes for people to
understand and
the harder it becomes for hardware to
run it which might not be a problem for
streamers or hardcore gamers who are
running 30 70s somehow if anybody
actually has a 30-70 right now
but it's it's going to be a lot harder
for academics writing about this game
and publishing papers about it or
people in city governments thinking
about using this game in any way but
don't really have the the computing
power to handle it
so i think whatever it is that you're
doing you want to strike a balance in
here and especially in the core
community of this game it's been
shifting so much more to heavenly
modding and adding lots and lots of
assets and everybody getting
64 gigs of ddr4 ram just to be able to
handle their thousands of workshop items
and
inevitably if you want to do something
with city skylines to a broader public i
think you have to scale it down a little
bit and i think for instance bifa is a
good example of this of making the game
more approachable to a more general
audience
maybe the hardcore city skylines nerds
are gonna roll their eyes and
um
watch somebody else but i think that's
also fine there are different roles for
different people to play
but all i'm thinking is that in
presenting city skylines to the outside
world
you have to look at this balancing act
of which mods do i want which assets do
i want and which are cool but not
absolutely necessary
to try and keep things as simple as
possible
and i think you can very well create a
list of absolutely necessary mods and
stick to these and stick to custom
assets only in case when you really need
them or try to keep the amount of them
low which is essentially what i'm doing
with this build here as well
um but it's something to think about i
think it's
way too optimistic to present city
skylines as a game where you can do
anything and you can build anything you
want because yeah well it's technically
true
if you get into that territory it's
going to be super labor intensive to
build those kind of cities and it's
going to be really difficult to run them
on pcs and it's going to be especially
difficult for anybody who's not a city
skylines expert to even stand to even
understand what the hell is going on so
yeah this is uh one of the the biggest
paradoxes i guess and why i think
modding is both a bad and a good thing
and i'm always trying to balance it out
um but i don't know what exactly the
right balance is maybe traffic manager
isn't completely necessary maybe you
don't even need that many assets at all
and you just need some graphics mods to
change the the look of the game a little
bit but otherwise stick to vanilla and
just try to re realistically recreate
the layouts of cities or maybe you
really want all of your buildings to
look exactly the same and
try and be as close as reality as
possible and go into a detailed level as
well
i don't know where exactly the right
answer is
but it's uh
it's it's how i would like to frame the
conversation and i think it's one of the
most important things to to think about
if you want to do anything with the
cities
in an urbanism perspective
if you just want to detail then of
course by all means just go ahead in
detail and if you want to play the game
vanilla honestly
i still do from time to time every now
and then i just turn off all of my i
just do the no workshop and disable mods
commands on steam and just play the game
vanilla because
all things considered it's still really
fun and just its core game mechanics
still hold up and even if it's not as
realistic or
detailed
it's
still just a fun experience
now before i get back to talking about
brussels just something that i quickly
want to mention that i really should
have had in the last segment but i
forget about it
my computer is still horrible and i'm
still running on a really old rig that
i've been making youtube videos on since
forever as long as i can remember and
it's really due for an update but
turns out that
2021 is just the worst year ever to
think about upgrading your pc because as
much as i want to it's completely
unaffordable and honestly at this point
also new parts are unorderable so it
looks like i'll be stuck like this for a
while but one of the the biggest caveats
in in terms of brussels i should add is
it's really hard for me to actually run
the simulation in the game as long as
it's paused and you might notice that
it's paused for most of the time
whenever i'm playing
it's still fine and the frame rate is
okay um but if i unpause the simulation
just stops to a crawl and it's really
hard
to actually get it to simulate the city
itself
which also means that brussels is just
kind of superficial here and isn't
really simulated
if i had a better pc then maybe sure i
could have actually run the city and see
how the traffic is doing i had a bunch
of comments talking about the traffic
which is
very
appropriate because brussels i believe
is still the most congested city in
europe um but yeah unfortunately i can't
really look too much into that and this
is all just a pretty picture here
but traffic in brussels
is definitely interesting it's it's one
of those things that kind of makes
brussels what it is isn't it
a city that has to then has to have so
many problems but also has its charms
and
one of the reasons i think it's just so
congested is it's one of the densest
cities in europe if you look at a map of
density in in european cities brussels
is up there with paris uh and way denser
than cities like amsterdam or berlin for
instance
so that's one part of the equation and
then also it just doesn't have good bike
infrastructure so it doesn't really have
the
share of mobility of cyclists as
amsterdam has for instance
pedestrian spaces aren't too optimized
either and there is a lot of public
transport
actually
i believe about a quarter of the city's
budget goes to transport alone
but a lot of this is also kind of bogged
down by the traffic issues because many
of the transport it relies on are bus
lines and tram lines that go on the
streets and sometimes even
have to share all of their space with
the one
car lane that's on the same street
so lots of issues there
and
traffic congestion is definitely one of
the uh
iconic parts of brussels i guess
in many ways it's also actually the
result of car-centric planning brussels
has a bunch of car tunnels going through
the city center mostly alongside the
pentagon ring road that goes around the
city center and most of this
infrastructure was built around the 50s
and 60s in time for the world expo that
was held in brussels where also the
atomium was built
and
well modernist urbanists at the time
remodeled the city in a vision of car
dependence and releasing the car as a
vehicle for future travel and
it's created this
ironic state where building
infrastructure for cars creates induced
demand and makes people drive cars
around the city instead of using other
forms of transport and as a result
people rely on cars a lot in brussels
and
even though it has
if you look on paper
more car specific infrastructure like
um
well underpasses and things like this
than other cities in europe it's more
congested as well because it's the it's
more difficult to use alternatives and
so the old
uh slogan of building other types of
infrastructure to fix the problems of
car infrastructure
really applies to brussels as well um
and i think they're doing great strides
in that sense so for instance during the
corona crisis 40 kilometers of new bike
paths were created
and they're working on a new north south
metro line as well which there are
opponents and
supporters for and i'm not even entirely
sure which camp i'm sitting in
but altogether the city is definitely
doing things to try and fix its
congestion issues but i think it's
it's honestly a stereotype that it
deserves uh to be one of the the most
congested cities in europe i just really
hope they continue to be able to do
things about it and open up streets to
other forms of transport and also just
life in the city
so that's something i just quickly
wanted to mention i also had some
comments on the last video that people
were disappointed that they saw me kind
of moving toward their neighborhood and
they're not quite really going there
which is a shame everybody likes to see
their streets being placed in the map i
guess
unfortunately not everybody will see it
because i did cut out many segments of
this time lapse because keep in mind i'm
laying down every road in brussels here
and some parts are just maybe not that
interesting or it's just a lot of the
same
so i decided to just highlight some
clips of the time-lapse here
but also there are just some parts of
the city that i didn't get to in the
last episode and this would be one of
those areas the area of jet and laken
and cuckoo berg
which i i got a small part of goku bear
in the last episode i think but i didn't
quite go up this much
these neighborhoods are
interesting because they're not quite as
dense as much of the rest of the city
this is also where the area with the
atomium is located and the gardens of
the the king's palace
um
so definitely lots of things to see here
especially for tourists as well
actually one of my favorites tourist
attractions which is the
the gardens they have beautiful huge
greenhouses that are open every spring
and
i wait i said this in the last video
already anyway if you're ever around
brussels definitely check it out because
they're awesome but yeah that's what
this area is all about now let's go to
the last area that i wanted to show you
guys because i think it's one of the
most interesting areas of the city
definitely one of the most dynamic and
also
i think it turned out as one of the best
neighborhoods in this model
so we're getting to the area of the
north quarter and the surrounding
municipality of skarbig here
which
is interesting um because the north
quarter itself which is the neighborhood
that surrounds the north station
is one of the unbrussels
neighborhoods that's a disgusting word
i'm very sorry
but yeah it's very unlike brussels
brussels in general has a very organic
urban fabric with
many 18th and 19th century buildings
lining curvy streets and
no
specific overall vision or recent
modernist urban planning but the north
quarter is an exception to this it used
to be an old 19th century uh
working-class neighborhood until it was
raised to the ground in the 60s
for modernist ideas of large car-centric
boulevards with skyscrapers next to it
and in that vision only only a part of
it was really completed and i believe
only
six or seven of the skyscrapers
depending on how many new counts since
they are working on a few right now
ended up being built around the north
station
and eventually in the last few decades a
cbd has been growing around this so you
can already see the skyscrapers
around this area here on the left of the
screen
and most of these at this point are a
bit newer than the original manhattan
plan as it was called
because of course when you're building
skyscrapers in the city you have to look
up to manhattan i guess because that's
the the end-all be-all example
um but yeah it's really become sort of
the cbd of the city at this point and
really unusual uh compared to the rest
of the city in that you have none of
these uh quaint narrow belgian houses
and and none of the curvy bendy streets
that you have all throughout brussels
but instead wide straight roads on a
grid pattern with huge buildings that
if i can get very personal and just
share my opinion i feel very out of
human scale and
one of the worst things frankly that has
ever been done although even nowadays i
still do like going there because it's a
really interesting neighborhood
it's dynamic it's a neighborhood where i
feel like a lot can happen and
a lot will be done in the future so in
that sense it's really interesting
it's not quite as static as some other
neighborhoods in brussels
but yeah that's what makes the the north
quarter so interesting and skarbic which
is a municipality that
at least partly also includes the north
quarter and the cbd
is right next to it and is one of the
densest parts of brussels and the
absolute opposite it's all these bendy
roads narrow streets uh old houses uh
really interesting
it's also as some people pointed out on
the last episode i guess uh this area
around here is also the red light
district of brussels
um but yeah all
uh complete opposite areas in terms of
of urban structure which is uh which is
interesting i think one of the things
that makes brussels a nice city to
recreate in city skylines at least kind
of doable is the fact that most of the
city
looks so similar and most of it really
is just a curvy
messy road pattern with
organically grown almost houses around
it obviously everything was kind of
planned at the time but looking from
above you can see it's a it's a very
messy road layout um
and it makes it much easier than for
instance some cities that uh look a lot
more bland like dutch cities where you
could have buildings being set back from
from from streets and very specific kind
of architectures in different
neighborhoods
brussels doesn't really have any of that
it's it's very similar everywhere and
the north quarter is a small exception
to that but even that is not too
difficult to build in the game um so
it's actually
a really great city to try and recreate
in city skylines if it weren't for the
fact that it's so absolutely huge
the amount of people which you count to
the city of brussels is of course very
difficult to pin down um depends on if
you want to base it just on the city
itself so the municipality or the the
region of brussels or even the
metropolitan area which includes some of
the surrounding towns in flanders that
even though they are in a different
region are directly connected to
brussels so pretty much part of the same
city
anyway
but the the estimates of the functional
metropolitan area of brussels sit
between two and three million which
is quite large and also quite a bit
larger than oslo and
in my idea just
maybe like 25 or 50 percent too large to
realistically recreate the whole thing
in city skylines you have to end up
drawing some boundaries
somewhere and
for me that ended up just being some
outer ring roads where i decided to not
expand into any of the suburbs beyond
that because it was just not doable in
terms of the node counts
so that's why i put emphasis on closing
the ring roads and finishing the parts
within this to try and get at least
somewhat of a natural border to the
places that i've built in here
anyway that's all for today i'll see you
guys next time in a video where most of
the roads will have been placed and i'm
really
not able to squeeze any more roads out
of the node limits anymore and it's time
to start zoning things and let the
buildings grow out of the ground so
thanks for watching everybody and i'll
see you next time